some huge unexpected news James Gunn
coming back for guardians of galaxy
three and also doing the Suicide Squad I
was curious what your reaction was when
you heard that I'm proud of him I'm
happy that he's coming back I'm so proud
of Disney actually that not all the
leaders right now behind that big
corporation you know decided to lead by
example and spreading the word and the
message of redemption you know is is
important I remember a few years ago we
were at comic-con in May had launched
brie Larson as Captain Marvel and you
were so excited I'm curious if you had
the chance to see the film yeah I loved
it I loved it so much I'm so proud of
her I'm so proud of Marvel Studios I'm
also so happy that the public received
it and they really supported it because
that was the other that was the main
part of this whole equation we need we
need we need to go and support these
movies with female leads in order for
for our our corporations to understand
that there is business and investing in
female Narron and narratives you know
while we wait to find out if Gamora will
return to the Marvel Universe you can
see Zoey as adventurer
Adelina fortnight in missing link what
qualities did you admire about her as a
character she has a true sense of
justice so she's not going to allow
Lionel to take advantage of mr. link
also she finds herself displaced once
again you know she's an immigrant she
buried her husband and now she finds
herself like questioning what do I do
Who am I where do I go so she's in dire
need of an adventure she embarks on this
adventure with them and instead of
discovering herself he discovers herself
but discovers that being selfless is
part of self-discovery as well being
there for others
[Music]